good morning John and thank you ever so
much for here
truth or fail on animal sex cuz boy I I
couldn't live without knowing that stuff
but you missed the most fascinating
thing about the traumatic insemination
of bedbugs O'Dare huge some bedbugs
stabbed their sperm through the thorax
of a female to inseminate her and that
is weird engrossing kind of horror but
the men also do it to each not because
they're you know just like willy-nilly
stabbing everything they can with their
sperm spikes but because and this is
crazy they are actually shoving their
sperm into the other male to mix their
sperms together so that male is
successful and inseminating a female
there is a chance that the sperm that
actually ends up fertilizing her eggs
will be the original sperm stabbing
males actual video topic you may have
heard that a small particles function
both as particles and waves and it's
difficult to understand how weird this
is but there's a great video that you
can watch that will actually explain it
to you and then your mind will melt and
you will never be able to function
correctly as a human again you should
watch that video there's a link to it
right here there's also a link to it in
the description but here's the thing
electrons are very simple they're as
elementary as you can get but even
electrons are difficult to categorize
wave-particle both we are orders of
magnitude more complicated than
electrons in yet we still attempt to
categorize ourselves indeed today is
National Coming Out Day in the UK and it
was yesterday in the US so let's get
this out of the way when I was a younger
man I was a bit of an electron I wasn't
sure if I was a particle or if I was a
wave unless someone was observing in
which case I was definitely a particle
some people know if they're gay or
straight by the time they're five years
old I kind of think that those people
are the exception rather than the rule
and by the time I reached puberty I knew
that being gay came along at least
theoretically with several social cues
for example if someone was a little bit
more flamboyant than usual if someone
was a big fan of ice skating and really
loved his collection of stuffed animals
and hung out almost exclusively
girls but in a non romantic way those
social cues came along with
homosexuality and so I thought I might
be gay and this was scary for me because
I really did want to be different I
remember very specifically uh ice
skating while listening to the Village
People and it's just idiotic but you
know I'm a kid I'm 12 years old and I'm
worried about being different and I'm
like I like ice skating too the Village
People so much this is a problem it
sounds funny but it isn't it's not funny
for a lot of reasons one because someone
can be so afraid of what they might be -
because just because you like ice
getting to the Village People doesn't
mean anything about your sexual
orientation so it turns out that I'm not
gay what I am is kind of effeminate I'm
sort of a less gaius kind of guy sexual
orientation is very complicated and it's
rarely 100% in either direction I'm like
a Kenzi one or two heterosexual it's
hard to recognize that especially
because it makes a mess of all of our
exemptions about what gender roles and
sexual orientation are supposed to mean
about Pete an electron or a person I
would want to know a heck of a lot more
about that electron then whether it was
a particle or a wave before I made a
judgement about what kind of person /
electron it was here's my message on
National Coming Out Day in the UK be
honest with yourself be honest with the
people that you love be honest with
yourself even if you're not quite sure
who you are because most of us are
unsure of who we are I mean that's a
very difficult and huge question to try
and be who you are and be as honest with
yourself as you can be unless you are a
bed bug in which case just stop John
I'll see you on Friday